(mesmerizing music)
- Past life regression therapy
is for anyone who
believes in reincarnation.
It's for anyone who believes
in the amazing healing power
of the conscious and subconscious mind.
Let's make a commitment today
as you go on your past
life regression experience,
you're not gonna worry if it's fantasy,
imagination, metaphor
or memory.
The best way to do past life regression
is to write down your intention
for having this experience.
Make sure it's an intention
that will make your life
as a son or daughter of the 21st century
more authentic, more joyous
and better for you.
Some intentions might be,
well, to discover why I have a pain
or an illness that no
doctor can help me with.
Maybe it was a death
wound from a past life.
Maybe you're having a journey
with someone in this life
where there's a repeating pattern of pain
and you want to find out if you traveled
with that person in the past.
Perhaps
you would like to discover a solution
if you're having a dilemma
right now and you want to see,
did you have that
dilemma in any past life?
What did you do?
How did it turn out?
So you can make a wiser decision
in the here and now.
I have with me today
David and I have Sequoia.
Both of you, think about an intention
about why you want a past
life regression experience.
And how it might serve
you as a son and daughter
of the 21st century.
It's always best if you write it down,
that gets it anchored
into the subconscious.
Now we're ready to begin.
Get into a very comfortable place,
you can sit in a chair
like you are meditating
or you can lay down any place
that you're most comfortable.
Keep your eyes open
and pick one spot,
a single dot, high up on
a wall or on the ceiling.
Now stare at it.
As you stare at it,
you'll find that your eyes
get very, very tired.
And your eyes begin to blink.
On one of the blinks,
just go ahead and allow
your eyes to close.
With your eyes closed, you're gonna feel
some very pleasant little fluttering
right under the lashes.
When you feel that,
breathe the word 'deeper'
right in to the bottom of your toes.
Now draw all of your attention
to the soles of your feet.
And breathe in your power word.
Your power word today is the word
(snapping)
trust.
As you breathe in the word trust
into the soles of your feet,
up into your ankles and calves,
your calves and your knees,
your knees and your thighs,
you can let all of the muscles relax,
wonderfully, totally and completely.
And now imagine
what it would be like to
(snapping)
trust your powerful legs.
No longer to use those legs
to run away from anything
but instead use those powerful legs
to journey forward
towards your goal of
fulfilling your intention
of discovery
for a better, more joyful life today.
Now breathe the word trust
right into the pelvic floor
and there you can access
intuition
and wisdom.
Now breathe the word trust
right into the appetite,
you can trust your appetite
to only have an appetite
for yummy, delicious,
nutritious foods
that nurture,
nourish
and heal
the body,
the mind
and the spirit.
Breathe the word trust into your heart.
And as you breathe the
word trust into your heart,
you can breathe it in as a
beautiful white and silver light.
And you can let it light up any dark areas
where there's been rejection,
loss,
sadness or even disappointment.
And breathe in the word trust
like a beautiful bright,
white and silver light.
For you can heal yourself
in the present
by understanding the past.
If there's anything you're
holding on your shoulders
that no longer serves you,
release it.
Let the jaw relax and the teeth part.
You can
remember
a yummy, delicious, nutritious meal
that you've had recently.
Remember what the food looked like.
Remember conversation around you
if you were watching
a TV or even Buzzfeed.
Remember what the topic was.
Or you can even remember
your own thoughts.
Remember what the food
smelled like
and tasted like
and what you felt like eating it.
Because you
can remember.
Now once again,
breathe in your intention
of why you're having a past
life regression experience.
What you want to heal.
What you want to learn,
what you want to achieve,
what you want to release and breathe in
that intention for having
this experience today.
And now make an image of
what you may look like
with your eyes closed right now.
Ask your soul self
to detach from your body
and let your soul self
drift up even higher, higher
looking down at your body.
And let the soul self drift
right through the ceiling
so you can look down at all
the rooftops all around you
in your mind's eye.
And you can imagine or
visualize, picture or pretend
or even just get a sense of
what all the rooftops look like below you.
Now drift up even higher
even higher
drift up even higher
so that you can see some bodies of water.
And drift up even higher so you
can see the entire continent
where you live.
Drift up even higher, let the soul self
drift up even higher so
you can see our beautiful
blue green planet,
like a marble,
spinning on its axis below
you with a cloud cover.
And let the soul self drift
up even higher to a dimension
beyond space and time
and in this dimension,
there is a big tree floating there,
it's the tree of life for
all that hold fast to it.
And let your soul self perch
on top
of that tree.
And it's like nothing
you've ever experienced
or even ever imagined.
And you can look around to the infinite
horizons in every direction.
But now look back down at
the Earth and use the power
of your mind
to see the Earth
and in your imagination, picture, pretend,
visualize, imagine or even get a sense
that you're so powerful
you can slow down the Earth
and then it stops
and now let the Earth
begin to rotate backwards
on its axis, yes, you are so powerful
you
are reversing
time.
And you can watch the Earth change.
The continents, the
waters, the ambient light,
the forests,
for we are going back
in time and when you're ready,
again,
breathe in
your intention
for having your past life experience.
And you're not gonna worry
if it's fantasy, imagination,
metaphor
or memory.
For you made that commitment to honor
the experience, the conscious
and subconscious mind
has for you, it's true.
And now, as you remember your intention,
the place in time that
answers your question
is going to pull the
consciousness towards it
like a magnet.
And as I count,
from 10
backwards to zero,
let yourself get pulled towards
another place,
another time,
where you'll be able to see
through younger eyes,
hear through younger ears,
the Earth
was a younger Earth
and it will be imagination, visualization,
it might be like a memory,
like a dream,
like a fantasy
or like a story told by an ancestor
around the fire
long ago.
And here we go,
nine
eight
seven
six
pulling in towards the hemisphere,
the continent,
the time,
the country,
the city,
the town, the space,
five
four
three
two
one
zero.
(snapping)
You are there.
Look down at your feet
or even in your imagination like a memory,
what are you wearing on your feet?
Or are you barefoot?
What are you holding in your hand?
What is covering your loins?
Are you a man or a woman?
A boy or a girl?
Or are you in a culture
that's beyond gender?
Look around you at the vistas around you.
Orient yourself
in space
are there swamps?
Or villages,
desert,
ocean, forests,
towns?
And orient yourself in time.
Listen.
Is someone calling to you
or do you know your name?
In what place are you?
In what time are you?
In this other place, in this other time.
And now,
breathe in your intention
for your past life regression
and let
the soul self
pull you towards the event
or events
that will fulfill
your intention
with five,
four,
three,
two,
one,
zero.
You are there.
Are you alone?
Are there other people?
Is it safe or scary?
Is it
warm or cold?
Do you recognize
anyone
that you may travel with
as a son or daughter of the 21st century?
Do you recognize anybody else's soul?
For soul groups have a
tendency to travel together.
What is happening?
How does it reveal the
answer to your question?
Now it is very,
very safe
and very educational and very
revealing and very healing
to find out how you
died in that past life.
So with no emotion,
and no pain,
let yourself travel
to the moment
after you died in your past life.
What was the death wound?
Or was it disease?
Or natural causes?
What part or parts of the bodies
gave out
so that you went from this
world to the world to come?
And let your soul self
feel lighter and lighter,
light as a feather,
lifting and rising, lifting and rising,
higher and higher, up, up, up
until you arrive
at the world to come
where you will reunite
with every incarnation from
every life in the past.
But you will also reunite
with all the wisdom
from all the lives you
will live in the future.
When you see
the next evolution of humankind.
And now you have all that information,
wisdom, perspective and insight.
You now
can ask a question
to your wise self,
the compilation
of all
of your lives, past, present and future.
(calm instrumental music)
But now ask this question,
"Wise selves,
"what can I take from this experience
"to make my life
"as a child of the 21st century
"more joyous,
"more intentional,
"more authentic
"and better
"so that each and every day
"I can be proud of myself?"
And listen very carefully for that answer.
It might sound like a wise voice,
like the daughter of the divine.
It might be a feeling,
an insight,
a vision,
an idea
or just a knowing.
When you get that answer to that question,
memorize it.
And now,
(snapping)
breathe in that answer.
Right into the pelvic floor
and make it a part of your life.
And as you do that,
you're so powerful,
you could use the power of your mind
to return
to the tree of life
and that dimension
beyond
time and space
and you can perch up
high on the tree of life
for those who hold fast to it.
And you can look down at the Earth
and use the power
of your mind
to slow the Earth
and let it stop
and then begin to rotate it back again,
going in the proper direction
so that time is moving forward again.
And when you do that,
begin to allow yourself to descend,
looking at our beautiful,
blue green marble.
Our home, our Mother Earth.
Coming down, seeing your
hemisphere where you live.
Your continent.
Coming down,
seeing
your county, your city,
wherever you're doing
your past life regression.
And come right through
the roof
and see your body there
with your eyes closed
and with your next breath,
come into your physical body.
And as I count from one up to five,
you will awaken, refreshed,
alert, feeling so much better
and you will remember who
you were in your past life
and everything you experienced.
As you think about it,
more and more and more details
will come up into the conscious mind.
You will remember
that wonderful gift
which was the answer to your question
from your wise self about
how can I use this experience
to make the here and now more powerful,
more authentic,
more joyous,
so that I can be proud of who I am
and always make wise decisions
for me
so that I can honor my highest intention
for myself, my family and everyone
who I have the privilege to meet?
One, two, slowly, calmly,
three is that nice deep breath,
feeling the breath in the body,
four is a very alert number
and five is eyes open,
wide awake.
Now when you're ready, pick up your book
and write down the
answers to the questions.
Write down in what way this experience
revealed the answers to your intention.
And in what way you're gonna make
positive choices in your life.
Because you know what?
You're too good to hang
out in your comfort zone.
And you want more out of life
and you're not gonna settle for less.
Because you know now
there's only one direction
and that direction is forward.
I hope you enjoyed your
past life regression.
Enjoy the rest of your day.
(calm instrumental music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.